speaking of the audition process I did
want to ask you also about spider-man
and what happened with all of that
because I mean again I like even
comparing it to Ender's Game you seem to
have handled that much more maturely
than I did where I get obsessed with the
movie and I get pissed at everyone
around me who doesn't love it as much so
you know taking that mentality to not
getting a big role like that I mean
what's going through your head when all
that pans out and what is the key to
making sure when you come out of it
you're staying focused on the future
because so so much good can come out of
not getting one thing that you might not
realize at the time it's true it's so
true and I've actually found with almost
every every every it's often you get
there's a part that you really want and
as a script people love and you kind of
put your heart and soul into it and you
don't get and it's tough
and it is [ __ ] but I often find that
something even better comes out a bit at
the end and so in the case of spider-man
I did sex ed because I I wouldn't have
been able to do both at the same time
and I think as an actor and going up for
roles there's only so much you can do
and everyone's gonna have a different
take on a partner and a different kind
of look at a character in different ways
and have a different performance and you
kind of have to stick with what you
think and if that isn't necessarily in
line with what director in the produces
one then there's nothing you can do
about that
you might just not be the right person
and that's out of your hands and there's
something I've learned something that I
think it's great to help me kind of go
over it because Tom did say amazing
things here and he had a toe entirely
different kind of betrayal and I think
it works so well in the universe and and
in that part and I don't think I could
do it so I think it all things work out
in the end